[Music]
right what this is the last session of
the show so thanks for coming to this
one I really appreciate it and I'm going
to talk about visualizing network
topologies and traffic but I have an
awesome team with me I have with me
Arunima who is a UX researcher she's
based in Seattle and I have Greg who is
an engineering manager working on
networking and tooling and he's based in
Wausau so I'm gonna introduce you to the
a January quick so we're gonna know what
we're talking about and let's talk about
traffic flows and how we do visualize
those in an on-premises Network I'm
always going to introduce with that and
then I'm going to talk about how we can
do it in the cloud today then I'm going
to give over to our Nima and she's going
to tell about research we've done on how
on what else users want about network
visualization and what we found out
there and then I'm going to segue to the
topology section and what's been
possible there till now and Greg's gonna
introduce a shiny new product we built
around that so let's get started with
traffic and I come from ISP background I
worked in a couple of ISPs I started as
a network engineer in Google so when I
made the switch to the cloud five years
ago I felt a little bit uneasy the tools
I've been looking at the - was I've been
using every day they don't work anymore
I was missing my tools the data wasn't
there anymore I couldn't find it and I
was like what's this is cloud
everything's different this is not good
I felt a little bit like kid on the
playground getting this favorite toy is
taking away but over time I got more
comfortable I realized you might have to
step a little bit out of your comfort
zone when you make the switch to the
cloud maybe you need to look a little
bit somewhere different for the data
you're looking for and it's not all that
bad so I'm going to introduce you to
death let's first look at what you might
have done in the past so when you
visualize traffic there's lots of tools
around open source and commercial tools
they all kind of do the same thing they
read some countless over SNMP they
aggregate them they take out like
overflow data and then they visualize
them and store all the data in a
database and that's how you visualize
layer 2 data so you can't get anything
about protocols if you want to dig
deeper you need to use any of these flow
like protocols NetFlow J flow F flow
more recently IP fix and they also all
kind of work the same way you have a
router or switch exporting flow data and
you have a couple of collectors who take
the data and store it in database and
then you have some tools to use that to
analyze the data around what's a little
bit different difficult it's getting
hundred percent coverage so in this
example here you can see we collect the
data right next to the firewall so while
everything going in and out is captured
you don't capture their data between the
service in other ways when you have a
lot of exporters you might capture some
flows double and then you have to
subtract them again so it's kind of a
little bit difficult so once you do
collect the data what do people do with
it and we see a few common use cases
there the first one everyone first looks
at is top talkers you see in your
network who generates the most traffic
outside of your network where does it go
to find anomalies or something like that
some people use it for capacity planning
because you get autonomous system
numbers you can decide whom I do you
want to peer with where do you need to
argument capacity something like that
and in the security area people might
look at anomalies small packet sizes
lots of UDP traffic and they either do
that through some specialized tools or
they export all the data in a science
system they're using across last use
case we commonly see is to verify other
data so I've been seeing in ISPs where
they look at net flow data to see if
their bill they get from another ISP is
correct
it's not something good enough and and
granular enough to actually create a
bill but you can double-check data you
generate in another way so that's how
you might have done it on premises no
how does that map to the cloud what what
data do you have available data let's
first look at interface traffic again
and you might not have found that top
but actually right into the in the TCP
console if you go to a VM there's a
network tab and you can visualize bites
and packets for every VM so quite
similar to what you've seen on the phone
the first sliding on premises with stack
driver monitoring you can create these
aggregate graphs you might get used to
so that's quite similar as well but you
might want to use your own tools you
might want to export that and stack
driver monitoring also has spectrum on
deterring API so you can export the data
and to any tool you'd want your existing
ones or you have something new and if
you ever wrote any tool that use SNMP
you will be very happy - not any more
use it but just use restful api instead
now there's also elements in networking
which you have in cloud which you don't
have the same way on-premises like our
global advanced that you don't have like
a global load balancing element and your
on-premise network and we also can
export some data data similar in the
console we can show you quite some nice
graphs of where does your traffic come
from which back-end group does it go to
but if you actually go into this deck
driver monitoring you can get further
metrics like we can see the round-trip
time on the front end and the total
roadtrip time of TCP flows and you can
use them right there to create alerts or
you can export them through the API we
also have a regional load balancer
product the metrics they are slightly
different but again you get some some
data around the load balancers respect
driver monitoring and it's API so that
looks quite good but what of what about
flow data well I'm pleased to say that
we recently launched VCT VPC flow logs
in GA so that's our flow level Network
telemetry
product so what does that mean it means
every five seconds all the TCP and UDP
flows get get locked and sampled and
exported to stackdriver logging so what
does it mean is it like net flow well
it's like net flow but it's not net flow
so what's different first of all you
have some exciting features you don't
have a net flow we can export the exact
IP of the flow we don't limit you to a
subnet slash 24 level and we had a lot
of useful annotations to it so you don't
have to do that yourself like the name
of the instance the name of the VPC
subnet the region zone etc on the on the
side and some more which I will go into
a little bit later but not everything
which is their net flow is there in VPC
flow works first of all we capture by
flow and not by packet so we can't give
you the packet headers we didn't see too
many people actually using the full
packet header so this seems to be ok
people also like the is numbers they
wanted to see PA p and destination es
well you might not really care about who
we appear with so that's not care about
paas but since people really want to
destination yes this is an annotation we
recently added so you can now see the
destination AS number right into the
floor log that's one of the annotations
but also not the same obviously it's a
different log format we have all this
useful limitation so you can't use the
existing collectors you need to build a
different data pipeline but we do have
exports right out of box too big very
cloud storage and pop it up and you can
create alerts on stack drive alerts
right for it and through these tools you
can easily integrate with other
third-party tools also gonna show that
let's look at the packet format a little
bit in detail and I say it's enriched by
default like other other providers might
give you like a single line of a log
which gives you a source and destination
IP a little bit more we give you
registration of information with all
these annotations like the instance name
and subnet name but also stuff like the
round-trip time
every TCP flow because we can infer that
from seeing packets going in both
directions or the location of the
external entity on the city level
country level or continent level so
that's very very useful and some some
data you might otherwise have to collect
very and add in a very complex way to
your data and your full coverage by
default you don't have to care anymore
where to put your expert to put your
exporters all the traffic within every
PC is done by the is by default exported
traffic coming in through interconnects
through VPN through the internet
directly to a via VM or through a load
balancer and to and from other Google
services so you see it all now you have
the data what can you do with it first
of all through the integration with
picker it's very easy to do click
realisations and i'm going to demo this
first data studio other people might use
something like tableau or anything else
which integrates in that area you can
also build complex data pipelines you
can use cloud dataflow if you like to do
if you can look your state up frog
instead or if you don't use it that
often you can just query that that data
ad hoc and build queries in bigquery
whenever you need it and in the security
space we see two use cases either you
export that data through pops up into
your Sime software and be tried out a
few it works quite easily or you again
when you have a security incident you
can easily just just sort a big fair
interface dig into your data and find
out what might be going wrong but let's
demo this switch to the gnome demo
please can we switch to the demo
Oh yet there we go all right so I have
an application built and it has a global
load balancer and it's running in three
continents and the simple web
application so let's start exporting
flow locks so all I need to do is select
the subnet we have on expert flow logs
so I select the US I added it I toggle
the flow locks and actually tells me
right away how much data that will
generate in stackdriver logging so let's
save this okay and within a few seconds
it will actually start generating that
logging information so let's go Stu
stackdriver logging and showed a life
tale of the data so you can see all this
locks coming in right away on what kind
of flows might be generated there and
you can look at the JSON data which I
see which I've seen so that works right
out of the box but looking there in
stackdriver logging not useful once you
want to do analysis so let's create an
expert off the data to bigquery let's
call it V PC flow logs next I say I'm
going to create it to bigquery and I
create a new dataset the PC flows great
so when I create that sink within let's
say a minute or two that gets true
streamed into bigquery and you can query
it right away all the data coming in it
it's near nearly immediate however for
demo purposes a minute is quite long and
also having a half a minute a minute of
data it's not so interesting to to look
at so I started this expert about a
month ago and have a live traffic going
on in there so let's see what I can do
with this I created a query with typical
top talker first thing you might want to
do yes
and to mix it up a bit I show you the
top a s numbers traffic is coming from
or going to
so let's run that query
and you can see it run - enough ii and
processed 1.4 1.1 gigs of data in that
case because just needed a few of the
columns and the top ASN i see there's
15.69 that google's own a ascends the
most of traffic is internal but then if
I wanted I could dig into all the other
traffic a little bit more but digging
into AAS numbers not so exciting let's
go a little bit more visual and let's
see what we can do with data studio
which is our visualization tool from
Google which can easily integrate this
big query I already connected the data
set to flow locks so let's create a
simple time series graph so that we set
up a time series graph I need a date
range I use actually the timestamp in
which the data is coming in and let's
say I want to see how much traffic comes
in by continent so I select as a
breakdown the continent destination
continent and I want to see not how many
records but how many bytes have been
sent between these from this continent
or to these continents and because half
the traffic comes in and half the
traffic goes out most of those are now
the US I want to filter these so I'm
gonna add this filter and it runs the
big very queries in the background and
within a few seconds basically you can
see how much traffic is coming in from
each continent so this is how either you
can generate one graph I pre created
some more just to see what else is
possible for example you can see a
simple heat map of failure traffic's
coming from or we can do something a
little bit more exciting here did
average round-trip time for my top
countries where the traffic is coming
from so I can use that for planning
which region which region I might want
deploy and so my top country is actually
India I have a very high round-trip time
from traffic coming from there I might
want to look into deploying the same
application in the mumbai region if it's
possible so that's what you can do is
data studio we also have third-party
integrations and as I said it works with
most major Siam software lock analysis
software and sumo logic has built
pre-created dashboards on VPC flow log
so you can just add the death but to
your applications connects stackdriver
log in through pops up and you seen see
all the data coming in and again you see
similar heat maps of where traffic comes
from and goes to you can look at traffic
by ports by VM by VP see is that goes in
come from awesome more complex
round-trip time average latency over
time to find anomalies or you can
obviously customize this dashboard with
any kind of queries so you have many use
cases for PPG flow logs can we switch
back to the slides okay back to the
slides please
so from the depth case on traffic flows
looks pretty good right we can do nearly
the same things we've done on-premise a
little bit different but also it's
easier to use that massive amount of
data you can have in the cloud but our
users one more and we did a lot of
research in that area so I want to
invite our aneema to talk about how we
did research in that area
[Applause]
Thank You yen's and thank you so much
everyone for being here as yen said I am
Arunima and I am a user experience
researcher in Google cloud platform and
I truly believe that I have the best job
ever because I get to talk to you all of
our customers and bring your feedback
into you know rpm and entity members to
build the product that you need and you
want
so as Lance was mentioning over the last
few months
me and my team members and with our
fabulous p.m. and inch team were engaged
with you to think about how to visualize
network topologies and traffic in GCP so
that we can actually understand what to
build for you well why did we want to do
that as yes
Jen's was mentioning if for some of you
who felt as when yen stood as that they
were a kid from whom some of their toys
that they had been using in on Prem was
taken away what we wanted to do for you
is to build new tools or new toys better
toys which will provide you a good
insight into you know and better
insights into GCP network so how did we
accomplish this I am a researcher as I
said and I wanted to take this
opportunity to tell you a little bit
about how we do research in Google and
avidin Google cloud platform for us it's
really really important to follow the
tenets focus on the users and else will
follow
why do we do this well this helps us to
identify whether a product or a feature
or a system will meet users needs so we
can build the right thing and understand
and gain empathy for our users so that
bill we can build the things right and I
do see some very familiar faces in the
audience so thank you so much for coming
you are the people that we've been
engaged with but we conduct
variety of user studies we do one one
one-on-one interviews we do site visits
so thanks for welcoming us at your you
know sites and also we do customer
workshops where we bring a lot of user
voice so that we can understand your
pain points finally we also do Co design
sessions these are really really
important aspects of user research and
the UX team because you know there's
three things that this helps us with one
to liberate us from our own mistakes by
you know replacing our own personal
assumptions with data-driven
requirements second it prevents us from
building the wrong thing on improving
something in the wrong way and finally
as I mentioned before enables us to
discover and the unmet user needs and
inform prioritization with rpm and ench
team so including these engagements we
listen to you what we heard that you
know you loved our load-balancing Sankey
diagrams and all the data that was
provided through that you also told us
and reached out to us about some of the
VPC flow logs that Yin's was mentioning
but you also mentioned to us that you
know even though these products and
features and visualizations are working
out for you you needed something more
there are some gaps and you wanted us to
fill that in and that's why i'm taking
this opportunity to talk to you about
these three things that we've heard one
is around visual representation and
another and around understanding the
network and finally diagnosing network
issues why we wanted to talk to you
about this is because if we've not heard
from you if you have other use cases and
you want to bring that information to us
that's amazing please do feel free to
talk to us we'll be here so one of the
concerns that you voice to us or the
pain points you talk to us about was
around the current state of visual
representation in our console what you
mentioned is
that what we have currently the list of
resources subnets and cloud routers and
VPN gateways etc they are stored in a
very flat list of resources a very flat
but that is not really useful to you
because in practice all of these
resources have relationship they are
interrelated and you want to see that
interrelation second we also heard that
you want to understand the network
configuration and layout some of the
feedback that we heard was it's hard for
you to understand what is connected to
what how your network VPC is set up is
redundancies working well for your
hybrid networking also the network
global state so where is the traffic
coming from which geographies it is
originating and where is it going and
how is the traffic being routed finally
and last but not the least we also heard
about diagnosing Network issues so
topics around troubleshooting
proactively monitoring issues and
alerting so when something is not going
right you wanted to understand
specifically where the problem is also
you wanted alert around network events
such as areas that are operating up
abnormally and then you wanted some
metrics based on latency error rates
data how the data is going in and out
etc so what did we do with all of this
data and specifically for those
customers who are here who we've reached
out to and we've talked to a lot this
does not go into a black hole we promise
we do look at all of the data we
brainstorm a lot and so that you know
your understanding your pain points and
what we saw is that the emerging theme
was that your needs where for tools that
will help you visualize monitor and
troubleshoot your system so that we can
reduce your operation operational
overhead so we wanted to build this tool
and for the MVP we actually wanted to
hunker down on two key areas that we had
heard a
again from you one was that we wanted we
needed to provide you with visual
representation of network relationship
and that too in contact so that you can
get to the core of the problem and the
second is that you needed metrics on top
of the relationship so what did we do
with this I would hold the suspense for
a little bit longer so that Greg can
come and talk about this but before that
just I want to have yen's come over and
give a brief overview of network
visualization and topologies in current
cloud because you are and in on-prem
world because as soon as we started on
the part of developing the network
topologies and visualization that greg
will talk about we had some reality
checks right the reality checks of what
you want and expect and what we can
provide you with that I hand it over to
yen's Thank You Arunima
so topology is important for everyone
and it always has been and unfortunately
it always has been difficult to
visualize so if you look at on-premise
the first problem starts with collecting
the data like what do you have in your
network you might be used a lot of
vendors different passwords etc so it's
not actually easy to get an inventory so
I said you need to use all the protocols
Cisco's discovery protocol link layer
discovery protocol see what you can
retire your SNMP community go through up
tables IP addresses and hopefully
somebody get an inventory of your
network the good thing is in compute
engine through the sub API of compute
engine API you have the inventory it's
all in compute engine so you have all
that data
the issue is context is missing you
think you don't know how to interrelate
it so let's see how we worked on that
first on premises let's say you
collected all that data you might want
to get a nice Network map like the one
pictured on the left but in reality
there's lots of tools around topology of
every network monitoring suite say they
have it but they're not really focused
on it
so mostly you end up at the graph a
little bit like that something
auto-generated and it's not really what
you want so what do people do well you
do it yourself
most people draw network diagrams they
draw them again they try to make them
better they customize them they show
them to your peers they have them read
it they make another view another layer
and yeah they're highly customized and
opinionated and then in cloud people try
the same thing but there's two issues
with that first of all it changes so
much so you just finished drawing your
diagram your network changed again
someone deployed something it's not
up-to-date anymore the second issue is
actually how resources are organized in
the cloud and on-premises on-premises
you have quite a clear structure if data
comes from the internet it goes through
several layers several aggregation
layers to top of racks which is until it
hits like your web application service
so you have some grouping right there if
you look into clouds you have a
software-defined network running on
Andromeda through a network fabric
everything is kind of close to each
other you talk through that virtual
switch you have a flat network so how do
you actually do that diagram some people
try to grouping this up nerd or
something else but it's it's not
inherent so it's structure is a little
bit missing and that's what's also the
first thing we've seen when when we try
to look what we can do for you and what
we made out of the research of our own
EEMA and those there's different
realities we have I'm going to invite
Greg and he will tell you ok so let's
take a moment in recap so what we heard
from you was pretty clear you want to
see relationships and then also need a
way to layer meaningful insights on top
of those relationships
however as Yin's just mentioned
visualize some cloud topologies is not
straightforward because the cloud is a
mesh everything is talking to everything
else it's like a web if you remember
that bundle of cables that Yan's had on
the screen earlier that's basically what
it looks like when you visualize a
thousand instances all talking to
themselves we're missing intermediate
devices those intermediate devices add
structure and make your topology look
nice clean and allow you to navigate it
effectively
so why is that a problem well without
those intermediate devices you have that
web you have so many things talking to
each other and you can't effectively
navigate them however those intermediate
devices also in a way structure you into
looking at your topology in a very
specific in a very unique way you look
at switches you look at servers that
attach the switches you look at core
switches and firewalls right and you
can't necessarily navigate in the way
that's natural to you in the way you'd
like to so we realized when we took a
step back is that we have an
organizational problem and we were using
intermediate devices historically here
in order to fill this gap of organizing
the data and allowing you to navigate a
complex network so we thought about an
alternate mechanism of structuring the
data in a way that allows you to
navigate it right and a natural way was
hierarchies if you take a group of
resources and group them together and
you take those groups and put them into
higher groups and so on and so forth
you can get to a point where you have a
very clean view and then you can drill
down and find exactly what you're
looking for the ability to select
entities and the ability to put them
into hierarchies is a key organizational
concern that's necessary in order to
visualize topologies effectively
unfortunately there's no clean hierarchy
for most resources it's unfortunate in
one way because it makes our lives a lot
harder but it's actually very fortunate
for you because that means you can group
things together in many different ways
an instance for instance could be in a
group it could be in a zone it could be
directly in a region or in a project
right there's a lot of different ways to
do it and rather than saying will create
one hierarchy for every base resource we
decided to create many hierarchies
before I give you a demo of the thing
that we're building now I want to
explain a few key concepts that are key
to this organizational structure all
right so first we thought about base
entities base entities are the things
that you're very familiar with things
that communicate on the network in an
on-prem world this would be a server
with a network card the network card in
our world would be a base entity but
also things like your external clients
things that have IP addresses outside of
your DCP network your on-prem your so
your VPN tunnels your routers on-prem
your
the things that your interconnect
attachments point to are all base
entities we took those base entities and
then we figured out okay what are
hierarchies that make sense so
hierarchies as I mentioned earlier are
just groupings of those base entities
that go higher and higher and then a
hierarchy family is a collection of
hierarchies that all ends at the same
base entity so if you have a instance
you can have many hierarchies and they
all form a hierarchy family these are
key navigational concepts that are
important
okay so we've organized the data and we
created a structure for it
so now what can we do well you saw VPC
flow logs before we also have HTTP load
balance or logs that are in stock driver
today we took this data and we started
to process it and what we were looking
for in this data was relationships and
metrics the same things that you
identified and let us know that you
really needed so let's put this all
together we create a meaningful
hierarchies and a way to structure the
data we took relationships out of the
VPC flow logs and their load balancer
logs that we were already receiving and
then we skimmed insights off of that as
well
actual metrics and then we applied those
metrics on top of those relationships so
I'm going to do a demo of a project that
we're building of a product that we're
building now before I get into the demo
I think a little bit of context is
necessary so in our demo we have a
worldwide ecommerce site this ecommerce
site is made up of fundamentally for
different applications there's a browse
component a cart component checkout and
feeds it's globally distributed in three
DCP regions
it's a world wide e-commerce shop so
that's important to them and the data
has to be replicated around the world so
this particular e-commerce shop is using
a database solution that's replicating
between GCP regions but all reads and
writes are happening locally all right
so now that you understand a little bit
about how the application is structured
how the company's infrastructure is
structured let's go into a demo of how
you can visualize and how you can see
the structure in action so thanks
okay so this is the product that we are
currently building we are in an early
preview of this product and what you see
here right is the Americas amia and APEC
you see a load balancer in the middle
and you see three GCP regions with
dotted lines moving all over the place
this is a visual representation of the
project I just described the dotted
lines are traffic that's flowing between
external sources a load balancer and
regions and this is all generated
dynamically based off of your projects
configuration and the actual things that
you have going on if this customer
decided to create a new GCP region
tomorrow or not create a new tcp regime
but build into one that would show up
instantly in this diagram so would have
walls and it scales with your business
now this view is a little bit
complicated because you see a mixture of
things that are coming through the load
balancer and also TCP traffic that's
coming directly from external clients
and going inside of GCP regions and
between them let's take a look at a view
where we're looking specifically at just
a load balancer all right so here you've
got three business regions America
Tamiya and APEC and you've got a load
balancer sending traffic to the three
regions just like on the other view
except there's a lot less lines and
still the cleaner so now when we look at
this right we can tell specifically how
this traffic is being distributed by the
balancer now let's go through a load
case that's important I use case that's
important as a network admin I might be
concerned about whether or not traffic
is going to the closest region to the
customer right the lowest latency will
always be achieved if the application
that's in that region is serving those
requests and it doesn't have to travel
globally around the world so if I hover
over a back I'll see some interesting
things first of all I'll see some
metrics on the edge I know they're hard
to read there but it shows that we're
receiving 12 kilobytes of traffic into
the load balancer and it's sending 60
kilobytes a second on top of that I can
see that all traffic that's coming from
a pack is going directly to the Asia
East one region which means that this is
set up properly looks good okay what's
next let's take a look at a Mia
a Mia same thing I see some metrics on
this edge how much is going to the load
balancer and then I see it's all
traveling to Europe but what happens if
I click on Americas in this scenario I
actually see traffic from the Americas
is going into two different places one
into u.s. central 1 and also into Asia
East 1 that's an indicator to the
network admin that hey something is
wrong here this is not optimized if my
customers in the US have traffic being
served by resources in Asia it's not
optimal for them if I open up a sure I
can take a look at the different groups
that are there I mentioned there was a
browse group a checkout group you see
them all here i go back i click on
americas and i see that the traffic
that's flowing through the load balancer
is flowing to just one of those groups
in asia if I open up the US central one
region
I see traffic is flowing to all of them
so this is an indicator to me right that
this particular back-end service which
is made up of three instance groups is
sending traffic to two instead of the
one that's most closely correlated with
the user now that I have this view I can
also use it to pull more information so
I can open up a load balancer and inside
the load balancer we see these are the
different back-end services that match
the applications we're just talking
about I can click on one of the backends
and get a time series graph right on the
side these are stack driver metrics that
show request count and back in Layton
sees for that back-end service because
this is a stack driver because these are
all stature metrics these are things you
can set alerts on you can use these
views to not only discover your network
not only see metrics but then also use
alerting in order to operationalize what
you're doing
let's go through another use case since
this is a globally discovered business
we have traffic moving between GCP
regions and as many of you know traffic
moving between GCP regions is costly
right it's costly in two ways one if
your application can't read and write
locally it has to pay a latency penalty
to send traffic across the world but -
it's actually money costly it has an
impact on your bill so we want to make
sure that all the traffic that's moving
in between GCP regions is traffic that's
only related to the databases no
applications are reading and writing
across the world so let's see how we can
do that with this view first I can hover
over a region and see how much traffic
is moving in between the region and
other regions if you've ever had to
debug an issue with wise my bill so high
for it to region traffic this would save
you a lot of time trust me
if I open up the regions I can see
instance groups again notice in the past
we saw for instance groups now we see
five the fifth one is a database servers
they're not seeing any load balancer
traffic so they weren't in the previous
view it wasn't important for you there
now if I click on let's say the database
group in Asia I can see that this
database group is talking only to other
database groups in other regions and to
all the applications local to it and
it's an early preview we don't have all
the metrics yet but in the metrics we do
have UC as well
all right so this is the amount of
volume that's happened that's coming
from the database group and going into a
different region if there was another
instance group here also sending traffic
we could focus on that particular group
and see those metrics as well all right
I couldn't go back to the slides please
all right so some key takeaways we have
VPC flow logs those are available in GA
today they're annotated by default and
easy to integrate with Google tools and
also third-party tools we have stock
driver monitoring which has been there
for everything not only for networking
there you can get time-series metrics
you can get logging
all networking specific as well but also
a programmatic API access to pull that
information and finally the network
topology graph so we're currently in an
early preview and we're opening for
trusted testers we're combining
relationship and metric data into a
single view and we're organizing it by
hierarchies to make it easy to consume
and are very much focused on the use
cases that you need to solve on a day to
day basis
[Music]